chris rock returned to the stage in
boston last night to kick off his ego
death world tour
marking his first public appearance
since the will smith slapping incident
during sunday's academy awards chris was
met with a standing ovation from the
sold out crowd before asking the
audience how was your weekend
but as far as getting into the incident
it wasn't going to happen last night as
he's still processing the whole thing
take a look
how was your weekend
before
this
weekend
and i'm still kind of processing
what happened like
like
so
at some point i'll talk about this
it'll be fun
yeah it's funny okay so in a new
statement released on wednesday the
academy revealed will was asked to leave
the ceremony following the incident but
he refused now according to a tmz source
will was never asked actually to leave
and was actually told by oscar's
producer will packer that he could stay
here's what would be goldbrick thinks
happened as she weighed in on the view
they come back from break yeah
now if he's in
some sort of state and he's struggling
and they're trying to get him out the
door
and it's still on camera
so it's a little bit you know listen we
we work a live show every day yeah we
work a live show every day and stuff
happens and it comes out your mouth or
you do something stupid and you got to
sit there and deal with it
i can't imagine what was going on that
wasn't there i can't imagine what was
going on back there but i do know that
the only person
anybody should be focusing on in my
opinion as well
and chris
and seeing if chris is okay
and a new clip is shedding more light on
what went down after the slap which
appears to show jada pickett smith
initially laughing
[Laughter]
[Music]
celebrities continue to share their
thoughts on the much talked about moment
with jim carrey addressing the incident
again while promoting sonic the hedgehog
2. after initially saying he was shocked
and sickened excuse me initially saying
he was sickened by the standing ovation
given to will jim now weighs in on the
bigger issue saying well cracked under
the pressures of society
you know i i was saddened by it and uh
and also you know i know that there are
things going on in will's life and his
relationship and it's a complex world i
see it as a larger issue and it's an
issue of
of the boundaries being broken you know
boundaries and allowances and
permissiveness to certain behaviors
you know and uh the fact is that that
that license is is being given to people
to act out violently when they don't
like what they hear
i also think that people
not unlike will
or
myself
we live in a lot of pressure
you know we set up a lot of pressure for
ourselves we're encouraged by this
country
to never stop and never be satisfied and
never look at our lives and going you
know what i'm enough i have enough
you know i've done enough
i don't need nine businesses i don't
need to be a movie producer director
writer actor star
and have a record company and be on tick
tock and be on social media and have a
reality show and share my innermost life
on some therapy show
it's
beyond our bandwidth
and we're starting to see the symptoms
of what it's like to be on be living
beyond your bandwidth and cracking under
the pressure that's what that was
it was more than just an insult to to
someone's wife jay is a tough girl she
can defend herself
she wasn't being physically attacked
what that was was someone who's
you know beyond the bandwidth and in
that moment he thought more about how he
was looking in that moment than what was
the right thing to do
and i don't condemn him for it it's just
wrong
i have never heard someone
hit it like that like he's not wrong
the whole society the reality show tv
society that we are all living in right
now
because really our social medias are our
own reality
he's not wrong i mean at some point
sometimes but it doesn't excuse it and
he does say that yeah but it's important
to always look at where people are
coming from
where chris is coming from where will is
coming from where jade is coming from
where different people from different
walks of life everything where people
are coming from when things happen and
that's why i said to my husband we were
watching it i was like the reaction
everyone's having right now on social
media will be very different tomorrow
because everyone needs to sit back
take in what just happened
instead of knee-jerk reaction knee-jerk
reaction knee-jerk reaction sure you
know yeah it's so much bigger and and
jim is right mm-hmm
like what is the
what is he says like the bandwidth limit
of somebody of anybody of anybody uh
yeah i don't know uh we all know what
our reactions were initially we've done
shock but we've done a story on this
story
every single day and we i was checking
with the comments and a lot of the time
and i love you guys i love that you're
here participating but a lot of the time
what happens with this uh whenever we do
this story is it does devolve into a
debate of whether he should or shouldn't
have done it like was is he bad for
doing this was chris rock at fault like
that ends up being this
being the debate and i think that the
the conversation around
um and for everyone involved right
what is your
uh bandwidth limit and are you taking
care of yourself so that you don't reach
a high pressure situation that you can't
handle
um
what is that right but but isn't there a
line of i mean i think that that's i
think that's what has people divided
there is a line
in life you know being physical with
someone whether it was on camera or not
you know that's a line
and the reality is
you know the average person at home was
watching this and maybe what normally
happens in hollywood say something could
be put under the rug normal society was
like no no no no you can't sleep that's
not okay like whoa what is this we adore
this man what we you know what what is
this
and so
you know everyday people are saying no
no wait a second here that's not right
yeah well you know we talked about this
initially like it was one of the first
conversations the dissonance between um
how you picture somebody because of what
they have put out into the world yeah
and
what that person is going through or who
that person is inside can be very very
it can be a very big gap and you as a as
a viewer are completely unaware yeah
until
sometimes this happens well i remember
seeing a clip recently there's been all
kinds of clips but another one recently
where will said seeing his father hid
his mother he had a something in his
head that said i will never let someone
hit my mother again
just having that moment where he's like
i will never let someone disrespect like
i'm not saying that that's what it was
but again you just people's experiences
and what they grow up with and all the
anyway i just i also just wish that in
society in general we had more peace and
grace for people and just slow down a
little bit
and just take a look at it you know all
sides chris will
everyone well it's yeah i mean
again like this is not anywhere near
finished and the conversation is going
to go on for quite a while
yeah sure